[Aplausos]
la desesperación se apodera de la
frontera sur de México en Tapachula
cientos de personas se aglutinaron para
intentar obtener un documento que les
permite circular por ese país y avanzar
hacia Estados Unidos ponen sus
esperanzas en el fin del título 42 el 11
de mayo una medida legal implementada
durante el gobierno de Donald Trump que
permitía expulsar a migrantes durante la
pandemia es el momento preciso para para
pasar yo voy con más seguridad de poder
pasar hacia los Estados Unidos porque
con lo que va a caer el artículo con el
favor de Dios Bueno en nombre de Dios
todos podamos pasar por la gente que
aquí hay mucha gente trabajadora que va
a
ayudar tanto a ayudar a Estados Unidos
porque nosotros vamos a trabajar duro
pero Estados Unidos preparó un plan que
haría más difícil el ingreso cuando
finaliza el título 42
los solicitantes de asilo deberán hacer
el trámite en otros países y programar
su cita por medio de una aplicación
virtual las nuevas medidas traen
consecuencias más serias para los cruces
irregulares como una prohibición de
reingreso de hasta 5 años Washington
anunció el envío de 1500 soldados para
apoyar las labores de la patrulla
fronteriza en la zona limítrofe la
medida es severa para organismos de
Derechos Humanos pero inútil para los
republicanos
me sorprende cuánta gente la
administración vaiden mientras Es sobre
la gravedad de este problema como el
secretario mayorcas que dijo que la
frontera Es segura Bueno si la frontera
Es segura porque el presidente envía a
1500 militares en servicio activo a la
frontera cuando no puede hacer cumplir
la ley de inmigración
según las autoridades cuando se suspende
el título 42 unas 10.000 personas Al Día
intentarán cruzar hacia Estados Unidos